nicole what's happening i have told my
husband many times about my love
languages
he's told me it's very hard for him to
do and from time to time it makes me
feel unloved
how do i navigate this yeah so what's
your love language
uh words of affirmation and physical
touch okay
and why does he say he can't do that
he says it's hard for him because he
didn't grow up
with that sort of love language um
and my family was always really into
those two
specifically yeah so
man i nicole i really wish i was talking
to him right now
um
uh there's no other word for it other
than it's just being selfish
it sucks okay um i wish there was
something else i could tell you i hope
you'll tell him to call me someday
um okay it's real annoying for me
it's really annoying for you too you're
living with it but it's frustrating when
any wife
has the courage and vulnerability to
tell their husband hey here's what i
need
when any husband has the courage and
vulnerability to tell their spouse
here's what i need and the other one
just goes nah i'm not gonna do that
oh my gosh nicole it drives me crazy it
really does
um but here's the thing he's not on the
phone with me and so i can't
talk to him directly and so i can tell
you what you can do
okay okay um the first thing is
do your best to have a
conversation that he can understand that
he can hear okay
and sometimes these love language
conversations come about
when people are exhausted or frustrated
or at the end of their rope
like you needed him to hold you on
monday
you wanted to be sexually intimate on
tuesday and he was playing video games
you wanted to
him just to tell you look nice on
wednesday fill in the blank and then
friday it just becomes an explosion
right
yeah instead of that conversation
set a time and this is a great season to
do this my wife and i take a retreat
every year
we will go to multiple coffee shops
we'll go to multiple places and it's
almost like a progressive
day and we will just talk about
different topics here's what worked well
this year here's where i want to lean
into being a better husband better
partner better parent this year
here's what i want to do professionally
this year and we just talk about those
things
this would be a great opportunity for
you all to do that
yeah if you will say hey i want to have
a little miniature retreat this year
and we can talk about things that we
love and don't love and it sets the
table for
i know you don't know how to do these
things i know you didn't grow up in an
affirmative word affirmation house
i know you didn't grow up in a
high-touch house
i'm going to teach you how to do these
things
i'm gonna teach you with these and it
may be nicole
a humbling process for you it may be you
getting a note card
or a text message that you send him and
say here are things i like to hear
okay and so if you um here are ways i
like you to touch me
and this can be like really vulnerable
this can be almost erotic you can talk
about here's things y'all may have never
had the conversations like hey when
we're
being intimate i really don't like it
when you do this i really love it when
you do that
we've never tried these three things
what are things you'd like to try right
if y'all have never had those type of
conversations this can be a revealing
opening
time and what i would call like one of
those deep roots conversations that
suddenly you get done from the table and
the roots of your
collective tree that y'all are y'all are
managing have grown way deeper and you
didn't even realize it right
but it starts with an invitation not an
attack
okay that starts with i need you to say
these six things and just practice and
it may be
oh nicole this is not romantic and they
don't write this up in the movies this
way
but it may be that you have a note card
that you give him
and when you are hurting you say this is
when
i want you to say this and he'll say it
and then i want you to say nope i want
you to mean it i want you to hug me
tightly
and you are literally walking him
through love language 101
yeah and is that super frustrating and
annoying yes
is that the way it was in titanic or
whatever movies
no but that's you investing and teaching
a guy that you love him the best way he
can love you
okay when i tell you that does that
sound gross and like
ugh or kind of awesome or just the way
it's got to be
no i like that idea i've never thought
of teaching someone a love language
before so i like
that kind of idea sometimes and again i
don't want to gender this because men
and women do this too but often men when
they
don't know how to do something it
translates to i won't
because i feel less than um
it suggests i'm not a man i suggest i'm
emasculated because you're asking me to
do something i don't have the skills to
do so i'm just gonna shut it down
right okay and so coming to him as a
teacher
as a and like i say if you make it sexy
if you make it inviting
and not shameful man you're talking
about a whole new avenue of your
relationship you may not even
have experienced before together and
make sure you invite him
to do those things for you what are the
things that
really deep in your heart and make you
feel connected
husband what are things that really get
you fired up
when i walk into a room and fill in the
blank what are the things that
make you feel distant and disconnected
when
you've had a hard week at work you've
had a frustrating conversation
with your dad and i say these things and
you feel like i blew you off
invite him into those conversations he's
probably never even thought about those
things or had those conversations
especially not with you what an awesome
gift you could give him
so nicole this is your new year 2021 you
and your husband are going to learn how
to communicate you're going to be a
teacher for him
again i'm going to say this over and
over everybody listening the world is
not a rom-com it's not a romantic comedy
it's not sometimes when we really love
people we have to teach them what that
looks like for us
and sometimes it shifts sometimes my
love language is touch sometimes it is
something else
and sometimes my wife knows oh right now
is when i should hug him and she comes
to hug and i'll say hey
not right now. and she's got to know
okay i'm not taking that personal he is
being vulnerable and telling me what he
needs right now and it's not this
great and if we don't take it personal
and we
lean into our partners as though we're
teachers
i mean you're talking about a whole
paradigm shift in relationships which is
awesome
thank you so much for that call nicole
i'm proud of you and then i want you to
call back after your retreat i want you
to have a retreat
call me back and let me know how that
goes i'm
i'm excited to hear how that works man
cause i think your husband's gonna come
around i'm optimistic he's gonna come
around